good morning everybody very welcome to
join us on the breakfast show seven
o'clock live from dining Street home to
prime minister Liz truff's spot for how
much longer after an astonishing series
of events another cabinet minister out
chaos in the Commons and a government
out of control the PM says she's a
fighter not a quitter but it's getting
increasingly more difficult to imagine
how she can hang on joining us shortly
the transport secretary Anne-Marie
trevelyn and labor MP Chris Bryant it's
Thursday the 20th of October
trusts in turmoil the prime minister's
Premiership hanging by a thread this
morning after a shock resignation and
Chaos in the House of Commons shouting
and shoving ministers deny allegations
MPS were bullied and manhandled into
voting with the government on fracking
at least one member was physically
pulled through the door into the voting
Lobby
hitting out if she Bowser the former
Home Secretary takes aim at the PM as
she becomes the second senior cabinet
minister to leave the government in less
than a week
as your patients grass through its
Tories tell the government to get the
house in order or the shutters come down
on the trust Premiership what my hope is
now is that they're going to sort it out
this is shambles
therefore honest she's got to get her
MPS coalescing around her and it's just
clearly not happening
a deepening crisis outside
which is is first ever emergency appeal
as food banks prepare for their toughest
winter yet
[Music]
morning everyone hanging on but for how
long Liz truss's government appears to
be on the brink of collapse after
another tumultuous 24 hours a Home
Secretary quit there were angry scenes
during a labor Challenge on fracking and
confusion over whether the chief and
deputy chief whip had quit solubman
accused the government of breaking key
pledges as she became the second cabinet
minister to leave inside a week
apparently for sending secure
information on a private email she
delivered a parting shot to the PM in
her resignation letter more chaos
followed with claims some MPS had been
physically manhandled and bullied into
voting with the government to oppose a
ban on fracking Downing Street says the
vote was treated as a confidence motion
and those who failed to vote with the
government without an excuse will be
disciplined our chief political
correspondent John Craig has more on a
bruising day here at Westminster
Zoella bravaman is out after breaking
the ministerial code but amid reports of
a shouting match with Liz truss she left
accusing the PM of breaking Manifesto
pledges after what had been a tumultuous
day in Westminster
this man grants chaps is now in charge
at the home office look obviously it's
been turbulent time for the government
but I think the most important thing is
to make sure that people of this country
know that they've got security and
that's why it's a great honor to be
appointed as homosexury
turbulent indeed
a night of chaos not only saw the PM
lose her home secretary and put in
someone who two weeks ago said she had
10 days to save her Premiership
but her Authority was further shot after
a key vote in Parliament ended in Fury
this was the scene in the no Lobby where
Tory MPS were voting against a labor
motion to ban fracking there was a group
including several cabinet ministers who
were basically shouting at them and and
at least one member was physically
pulled through the door into the voting
Lobby those allegations were denied by
cabinet ministers the eyes to the right
230 the nose to the left
326 so the nose habit the nose the
government won the vote but lost control
Debonair thank you madam Deputy speaker
I wish to on a point of order
um there are rumors very strong rumors
that the government Chief whip has
apparently resigned I wonder if it's
possible to get some clarity ours went
by our reports swirled that Chief whip
Wendy Morton a loyal trust Ally and her
Deputy had resigned I'm not entirely
clear on what the situation is with the
chief whip there has been an element of
confusion it took number 10 three hours
to confirm the pair remained in post
with critics claiming it's not if the
Prime Minister goes but when the
government gives the impression of
living hour by hour but MPS are asking
how many more does Liz truss have left
John Craig Sky News Westminster
joined now by the transport secretary
Anne-Marie trevelyn Mr Rebellion thank
you for joining us on the program this
morning did the chief whip resign last
night
so you've just answered your in question
there you have reassured everyone that
Wendy Morton and Craig Whitaker her
Deputy are still in post which is good
news they are no that wasn't my question
important members of the government
didn't ask you that did she resign last
night
uh not that I'm aware of no
so she didn't resign at any stage and
then went then was convinced to be back
in post
so I I wasn't there I voted uh early in
the lobbies and then had important uh
security issues to deal with at the
Department of Transport uh so I didn't
follow the imaginations in detail I'm
afraid I was busy doing my job but as
it's clear they are both in post and
that's good news
is it appropriate that MPS are
manhundled
I I uh well as I say I wasn't there but
I have seen not the point the photograph
that just about Australian it's going to
be much easier if you answer the
question let me answer the question okay
I will uh I don't think it's ever
acceptable uh for uh any party and we
have seen this happen before where uh
whips perhaps uh over reg uh their
encouragement to get people to vote in
the appropriate way that is that is
never right the one thing that our
Parliament is uh so revered around the
world for is that we allow each of us to
vote with our conscience and indeed with
our government on important matters
yesterday was an opposition day debate
and uh we uh won that debate and the
opposition day uh vote lost their vote
okay do you condemn whoever man handles
people through the lobby yesterday so I
have no doubt that Mr Speaker will look
into these issues and it is for him uh
to make the final examination I haven't
seen any footage Beyond Chris Brown's
photograph but it is never acceptable
for people to be uh manhandled into
voting do you do you condemn whoever did
it
well as I say I will leave it to Mr
Speaker to
um
well as I've just said it's never
acceptable uh for anyone to handle it we
should be able to vote uh absolutely as
we see fit on behalf of our constituents
and they are the ones who hold us to
account
um was it a vote of confidence in the
prime minister
I know yes there was an opposition day
uh debate and the labor party were
trying to uh use a parliamentary tool to
try and hijack the order paper that is
never acceptable so what it was was a
very important vote uh to ensure that
the government did not allow labor to do
that it's a tactic that has been used in
the past and previous governments have
also always made sure that those votes
are not won by the opposition
what's going to happen to those MPS who
didn't vote with the government
uh so I haven't spoken to uh the chief
whip this morning I thought I might let
her sleep in at the uh situation is
always very clear the the
Parliamentary managers will uh discuss
with colleagues who didn't vote with a
three-line whip uh why that was
sometimes they're a very specific uh
constituency reasons or indeed health
reasons and I know that uh the
appropriate discussions will go on as
they always do in these situations and
if there is a sense that some uh were
doing so for uh not reasonable reasons
uh the appropriate discipline will be
enacted but I would imagine most have
very strong constituency reasons if they
were unable to vote with the government
apparently the chief whip didn't vote
so as I say I haven't seen the list it's
quite often the case that the whips
themselves don't vote on both sides
that's quite common
okay um prime minister didn't originally
vote but then we were told that she did
vote
um and we were told by Downing Street
um in fact tomorrow was told by Daniel
Street at 1 30 this morning when you
finally got your ducks in a row that it
was a confidence vote and though the MPS
that didn't vote with the government
will be disciplined does that mean
they'll lose the whip
well as I say that will be a decision
that the business managers make no doubt
today as they speak to those as is
completely normal uh when uh colleagues
don't vote uh with the government
Direction uh those discussions are had
reasons are discussed as to why that was
the case and discipline uh or indeed not
uh delivered accordingly and we will let
the uh whips office and ministers do
that in due course
why did Sue Ella bravaman get sacked
so she resigned in her letter which she
put out yesterday set out that she felt
that she had fallen below the standard
by breaching the minister of Code by
allowing documents to be shared before
appropriately in an in an unsecure way
and she felt that she had you know let
herself down and therefore as she is
someone who has always worked with the
highest standards she is a woman of
Integrity she felt she had to step down
no she was forced to step down as we
know we can see that from the letter
um the Prime Minister if she'd wanted
her to stay she would have stayed or
perhaps it was Jeremy Hunt who wanted
her to go and then somebody who supports
Rishi sunak can be put in her post
so uh government needs to get on Sue
Ella resigned and Grant chaps was
appointed he is a man with a very broad
experience in many government posts in
fact he was my predecessor in transport
a man who understands the complexity and
the seriousness of security issues and I
know that he will do an excellent job in
picking up and managing those important
issues that the home office has to look
after
he's also a man who said earlier on in
the week that the Prime Minister for her
to be able to remain in post it would
have been like threading a needle in the
dark
well he wasn't a member of the
government when he was speaking of the
week now he is and I have no doubt
because I know Grant very well that he
will be an incredibly hard-working
member of the cabinet and I shall look
forward to working with him
yeah but he doesn't think she can
survive as prime minister
he is now uh the he is now the Home
Secretary which is an incredibly
difficult uh job and he will I know get
right stuck into it today and make sure
that all those issues that we need to
work on together to protect our citizens
to work on those issues uh uh on the
short straights uh The Wider questions
that we do in security uh are ones that
he is absolutely focused on we have some
really important and difficult issues
that we are all dealing with and what we
need to crack on with is making sure
that we do that and Grant will be a
great addition to the team
okay so just to clarify for me what was
it that first attracted the prime
minister to the rebel supporting uh
Rishi supporting
um back venture
sorry I didn't say sorry went correctly
on me sorry
okay I was just asking what first
attracted the prime minister to uh a
rebel uh who had been rallying the
troops against the Prime Minister who's
also a Rishi supporter why on Earth
would she put him in one of the great
positions of office
so uh I I would imagine I haven't had a
chance to remember what she wanted was
someone with uh experience who would be
able to come in and manage the
incredibly difficult issues that the
home office has to deal with every
single day it's a 24 7 job that one and
Grant has as I say enormous government
experience here obviously uh was uh
transport secretary before I was and she
will know that he can at you know very
short notice pick up the reins and
manage the many complex issues that
there are there including of course uh
you know dealing with the short strikes
and issue that I'm going to be working
closely with on those Maritime security
questions
Steve Baker who is an influential back
venture as you as you know but just for
the benefit of our viewers went uh on TV
yesterday speaking to one of my
colleagues saying that he'd been told by
Downing Street to say that swella
Braverman would be back imposed by
January
so I I'm afraid I didn't see that and
I'm not part of that what I uh can see
and knows the cases that Grant is Home
Secretary and that we all in government
in the prime minister's cabinet are
focused absolutely on supporting Jeremy
Hunt to stabilize the finances so that
we can get on with delivering the
services that are so important to our
constituents making sure that having uh
determined to fund the energy price
guarantee not only for our uh
constituents and in homes but also for
all our businesses so that we didn't see
a catastrophic uh failure of our smes in
particular that we make sure that we
demonstrate the city how we're funding
that and continue to deliver those
Frontline service that are so important
to our constituents
people up and down the country as you've
just been saying there are struggling to
feed their kids and we've got excuse me
politicians who are pushing and shoving
each other
um somebody who has been criticizing the
Prime Minister uh only a few days ago is
now one of the most important offices of
state two senior cabinet ministers have
been sacked in less than a week
um it's embarrassing
so politics is about looking forwards
and delivering and that's what we need
to do there are many very difficult
situations ahead obviously we have uh
the support that we continue to give to
our Ukrainian friends as the ongoing
Russian invasion and those battles uh
you know come into the winter months and
that's why the defense actually has been
in Washington working with our U.S
allies to support that we have to make
sure we can deliver this energy price
guarantee so that uh you and I and
indeed everyone more importantly who are
vulnerable and who are managing uh tight
budgets know that this government is
working alongside them I was pleased to
hear the triple lock for our pensioners
confirmed yesterday uh on the levels of
inflation these are really important
matters and what we have to do is work
together and government is absolutely
focused on delivering for our people I
am of course today okay bringing in
minimum service levels service levels
legislation which will ensure that even
uh if there are strikes there cannot be
an ability to bring down completely our
transport networks this is really
important to support those exactly to
say those hard-working people who need
to get to work nurses get into a shift
children getting to school business
people getting to their business
meetings these are situations that we we
cannot allow our Transport Systems to a
grind to a halt so we're bringing this
in so that we have a fair focus on those
who use the services that we provide to
make sure that they can always keep
moving these are really important
government activities which will keep us
keeping the country moving and growing
okay Mr Rebellion I know you to be a
woman of Honor are you not embarrassed a
little bit this morning about what went
on yesterday
as I say I wasn't in the lobbies but I
am uh shocked to uh hear the
descriptions of what went on as I say uh
we are uh well respected across the
world as a parliament where democracy uh
and freedom is at the heart of what we
do and I hope that uh Mr Speaker will be
investigating closely as I'm sure he
will to ensure uh that uh these these uh
scenes and in either situations do not
happen again what I want to make sure we
do also is deliver a four-hour
constituents that's what's so important
we need to grow our economy we need to
ensure that we can deliver the
incredibly important public service that
we can draw in with investment so that
business can grow because it is with
growth was absolutely right with growth
that we can do more for our constituents
for our fantastic Public Services okay
I'm going on holiday for a fortnight
tomorrow will this trust still be prime
minister when I get back I believe
you'll find she will be yes okay let's
see let's see it's good to talk to you
thank you very much nice to see you and
you
um tomorrow morning there you go she'll
still be there short and straw this
morning two weeks time says a member of
the cabinet honest honestly plenty of
people at the top of government wonder
whether that can indeed be the case
given the total chaos we saw in the
Commons last night I mean yesterday Liz
truss lost another member of her cabinet
the Home Secretary over a technical
breach of the rules that many of her
supporters uh think was perhaps not the
real reason with a really scaling letter
saying that she had concerns about the
direction of this government that she's
been a member of it for six weeks and a
barbed comment about how when you make
mistakes you have to own up to them and
not pretend that they haven't happened I
wonder what she's referring to there we
go to New Home Secretary by the end of
the day and astonishing scenes in the
Commons where Downing Street turned a
vote about fracking brought by the
opposition that they didn't even need to
participate in into a vote of confidence
against the Prime Minister then when it
appeared that plenty of MPS were simply
not going to go along with it they
claimed it wasn't then at 1 30 a.m I
received a text message saying it was a
confidence vote and this morning and
Marie trevelyn couldn't say what
reprisals what disciplinary action would
be brought against those MPS you simply
said I'm not going to vote for that
because I just don't believe in it and I
don't think the government should be
trying to Railroad people into doing it
how embarrassing is it for these uh poor
politicians you know who have to go out
do the morning rounds and and oh I
didn't see it I didn't see it I don't
know I didn't see it I mean and what is
this
it is embarrassing for members of the
cabinet who privately know that this is
total a total mess and the government
has lost control of events but also
there's really big important things
happening whether it's the cost of
living which we now know inflation is a
40-year high and food prices are are
soaring hugely important events like you
know a report yesterday into
um
maternity Services was a health sector
didn't find time to comment on until
about half an hour ago
the government seemed to be not in
control of what's going on and when you
get to that situation that is when
people really know that the Prime
Minister can't continue for that much
longer talking to those who are plotting
against her they don't really have a
plan they don't know exactly how this
might be brought to an end or when the
government could well as Ann Marie
trevelyn would say a limp on for a bit
longer but they have lost control of
events and once you've lost control of
events it's very hard to get it back
yeah I think there's a is it one of the
national newspapers that has got a live
stream of a lettuce to see which tofu
now as well okay to see which lasts
longer the lettuce or Liz trust
certainly she's in an awful lot of
trouble
um swella bravaman just to say I think
we are expecting her resignation speech
in the Commons
today yeah not confirmed yet yeah if she
does goodness me get given what she said
in her letter let's see what she says in
a resignation speech looking at the
papers for you uh this morning starting
with the guardian should we
um saysly Strauss is on the brink
following what it calls a stinging
attack from the outgoing Home Secretary
swella bravaman the express which has
shown more loyalty to Liz trust than any
paper describes yesterday's events as
beyond belief the financial times says
braverman's departure has plunged the
government into chaos
that word chaos features on a number of
front pages including the I
and on the mirror 2 which says that Tory
MPS have turned on truss
The Daily Mail looks Into The Showdown
talks between the PM and the Home
Secretary as well as 90-minute shouting
match with Liz is the headline the time
says yesterday's events represented a
total breakdown of party unity and
discipline and broken is the damning
one-word headline on the song
still to come on the program for you
this morning Chris bright the MP who
posted this picture from the commons
will tell us more about yesterday's
chaotic scenes
20 past 8 joined by the shadow Health
secretary West streeting
and at half past eight I'm going to be
speaking to the chair of the defense
select committee that's Tobias Elwood
an anti-poverty charity has launched its
first ever emergency appeal in order to
make sure food banks can survive what's
expected to be their busiest and tough
toughest winter yet Emma is at a food
bank for us in central London Emma good
morning
hello okay yes this is actually a
collection Hub so a few miles from here
in streatham there's a big warehouse and
what happens is that the food is
parceled up and brought here and
actually with this food bank it's to
individuals so for example here take a
look on this table is food enough for
two people for probably about three days
and in amongst it are some toiletries
but the fact is that usually there would
be a lot of reserves in place to get
through the winter where there is the
biggest demand and this time this year
the demand is out stripping the
donations which is why for the first
time ever there is this emergency appeal
and it's an appeal for money to help pay
for heating we all know about heating
costs for the 1300 food banks around the
country but it's also for food and also
for packs for winter and I'm going to
ask now Rebecca Gibson you're the
manager here
um tell me Tell me about these winter
packs yeah so we're making sure that we
provide for people this winter blankets
hot water bottles and also packs of food
that people don't have to cook or to
heat so they don't have to use any
Electric in order to eat the food we
provide so we're talking about people
who can't afford the food they can't
afford to put the heating on they can't
even afford to cook the food that you
give them yeah that's right yeah we're
seeing people in sort of worsening and
worsening situations of Crisis where
they can't afford to heat the food or to
buy the food in the first place what is
the demand been like so far this year
yeah we're kind of seeing it gradually
creep up and up and up and we're kind of
heading back towards levels that we only
saw at the very peak of the pandemic
when we had our highest ever levels of
need now we know that the money that is
donated will also be used for the help
through hardship helpline and one-to-one
sessions that are held in places like
this has the demand for that grown yeah
absolutely we saw a 50 increase in
demand for Our advice Services here last
month and we expect that to grow more
and more as we're trying to do things to
help alleviate the crisis and the things
that trap people in poverty in this
community okay thank you very much so
also out today is a report from the
consumer Group which and it has shown
um from a survey they did they estimate
that around six million adults say that
their households are missing a meal I
mean these are enormous statistics and
we're not even in the coldest months yet
so you can see why this emergency appeal
is seen as so crucial
okay thank you
also making news for you on the program
this morning very rainy here in Downing
Street this morning let's tell you
what's happening with Donald Trump he's
answered questions under oath in a
defamation lawsuit by an author who's
accused him of rape e Gene Carroll says
the sexual assault happened in a New
York Department Store in the mid-1990s
the former U.S president says Miss
Carroll made up the rape allegation to
sell books
one of China's top diplomats in the UK
has dismissed accusations that he acted
improperly against a pro-democracy
demonstrator outside the Chinese
Consulate in Manchester on Monday
speaking to Sky News the Chinese Consul
General who was accused of Kicking and
pulling the hair of a protester said he
acted as any reasonable Diplomat would
in the circumstances
I don't attack anybody
I'm the peacefully just that's not true
there is a console General you you
pulled the man's hair yeah the man is
because his abuse the country might
either
I think he said
Duty
to pull his hair yeah I think it's any
diplomats if I face to such kind of the
behavior
ofcom says small video sharing websites
based in the UK aren't doing enough to
prevent children from accessing
pornography in a report the regulator
said young people can easily access
content by clicking that they're over
18.
the U.S has announced criminal charges
and sanctions over a scheme to help
Russia's war effort in Ukraine almost a
dozen people are accused of purchasing
military technology from U.S companies
to pass on to Russia and of laundering
tens of millions of dollars for wealthy
Russian businessmen
president zielinski has again urged
ukrainians to resist being drafted by
Russia's Army in illegally annexed
regions his latest nightly address
followed Vladimir Putin's Declaration of
Martial law in russian-occupied
territories
please avoid it as much as you can
try to leave the occupied territory if
you cannot do this and find yourself in
Russian military structures at the first
opportunity try to lay down your arms
and come to Ukrainian positions
and the U.S President Joe Biden has
suggested that the Russian leaders
martial law Declaration was made out of
desperation
I think
that Vladimir Putin
finds himself in an incredibly difficult
position
and what it reflects to me
is it seems his only tool available to
him
is to brutalize individual citizens
in Ukraine Ukrainian citizens
to try to intimidate them into
capitulating
they're not going to do that
again everybody we are live on Downey
Street for you for the breakfast show
here on Sky News Thursday morning
starting to absolutely pour down as
we've been saying all week is it going
to rain on Liz truss's parade oh my
goodness me what on Earth happened last
night she has got a an absolute mountain
to climb she's declared she's fighting
on though after a chaotic day
[Music]
and this trust lost another senior
cabinet minister swella bravaman quit as
Home Secretary with a parting shot of
what she called a tumultuous Premiership
uproar and the commons where senior
ministers were accused of forcing
conservative MPS to support the
government in a contentious vote on
fracking
well earlier I spoke to the transport
secretary Anne Marie trevelyn and asked
her if she was embarrassed about
yesterday's events
as I say I wasn't in the lobbies but I
am shocked to hear that the descriptions
of what went on as I say we are well
respected across the world as a
parliament where democracy and freedom
is at the heart of what we do and I hope
that Mr Speaker will be investigating
closely as I'm sure he will to ensure
that these these scenes and in either
situations do not happen again what I
want to make sure we do also is deliver
a for our constituents that's what's so
important we need to grow our economy we
need to ensure that we can deliver the
incredibly important public service that
we can draw in with investment so that
business can grow because it is with
growth the publisher is absolutely right
with growth that we can do more for our
constituents for our fantastic Public
Services okay I'm going on holiday for a
fortnight tomorrow will this trust still
be prime minister when I get back I
believe you'll find she will be yes okay
let's speak to Lord Ricketts who was the
British government's First National
Security advisor and a former permanent
under secretary at the foreign office
lots to talk to you about this morning
thank you for joining us Lord Ricketts
first of all how embarrassing it was
last night
well I would say it was a shaming
experience I mean I look at it from how
the what Britain projects to the world
and to see the government in a shambles
the mother of parliament in that chaos
what an awful spectacle that sends to
the world I mean we have a government
that's in office but not really in power
anymore you can feel Authority draining
away from them that's bad for this
country it's bad for Britain in the
world
who should accept responsibility for
what happened yesterday
well there's one person at the top of
the government whose responsibility it
is to manage the business of the
government in Parliament as well as
towards the country that's the Prime
Minister uh you know the buck stops with
the Prime Minister and she has to be
held responsible for those scenes
and what sort of responsibility might
that take what might that look like do
you think
well I luckily I'm not a politician and
I'm not in the conservative party but
it's down to conservative MPS now to
work out a British prime minister with a
strong majority in the House of Commons
has enormous power but if she doesn't
have a stable majority and authority
over her own views and a capacity to
manage her business in the House of
Commons I mean that is a fundamentally
weak situation and we have a dangerous
world out there and people want Britain
to be an active player in you know
combating Russia and Ukraine on China
and so on at the moment we don't have a
prime minister with any Authority
internationally or domestically
how much of a problem I know you're not
a politician but you know you have been
uh within the heart of government uh
previously how much of a problem is it
when a politician who is uh who had high
office is sacked which is what happened
you know we've seen resignation letters
we know when politicians have resigned
and when they've been forced to resign
um then finds themselves on the back
benches
um I remember when
uh Mrs Thatcher did that to one of her
senior cabinet members and the
resignation speech afterwards basically
did for her
yes I think you may be thinking of
Jeffrey Howe um I am and certainly it
was a pretty devastating speech yes well
when a prime minister forces out a
senior member of the government whether
it's a former Chancellor of a former
Home Secretary you know that creates
someone with a grievance against the
prime minister they may decide to settle
down and be loyal backbenches or they
may not in the case of swella Braverman
the the Oddity really is that this was
not a very major
um you know misdemeanor sending an early
draft of a ministerial statement to
Parliament who's not a security breach
if you like it was a parking ticket
offense rather than a dangerous driving
charge and yet she was forced out and
then Unleashed that tirade of anger
against the prime minister so it looks
to me like the Prime Minister has
created another focus of dissent on the
back benches
so it wasn't really what she did it was
because uh somebody in one of these two
offices behind me wanted her out
yeah I mean that's what it looks like it
looks to me more like a pretext either
for the prime minister to push her out
or for her to jump before she was pushed
I don't know which rather than the than
the root cause and K what I mean I'm
thinking of this morning is thank
goodness for our wonderful professional
civil service because as the wheels come
off the government we have a civil
service which is keeping the country
going day by day men and women working
extremely hard they can do the day by
day running the country they can't make
plans and policies for the future and
that's what we need
I did want to ask you about the Civil
Service as well because it is something
that you know an awful lot about
um
what's it like for them day to day at
the moment when they don't know who is
going to be the head of the ministry and
they don't even know whether we're going
to have the same prime minister by the
end of the day
well it's incredibly difficult of course
because civil servants need Prime
Ministers and ministers to set the
direction to take the policy decisions
which they can then implement but if if
the government are basically you know
absent on Parade as they run around in
smaller and smaller circles day by day
civil servants will get on with the job
of running the country of doing what is
necessary within the policy guidelines
already set they'll do that very
professionally but it is extremely
difficult to have this level of chaos
and uncertainty from one day to the next
and decisions that need to be made for
the future urgently given the economic
crisis we have will not be being made
and so they can do the day by day
management but they can't do much more
than that thank goodness they are there
to do that
are you in the business of predictions
this morning my Lord
I'm never really in the business of
predictions I mean this government
cannot last in this state I mean whether
it's days or weeks I don't know but in
the state of the world in the state of
the country the crisis we have this kind
of chaos cannot continue and it's down
to Tory MPS to sort it out but really uh
you know we've got to put an end to this
get back to some kind of stability
and and how do we do that do we have yet
another prime minister who has not been
elected by the country or are we heading
towards an election do you think
I mean I all I can do is speak as a you
know as an individual and actually an
individual that doesn't have a vote in
general elections because I'm a Lord but
it feels to me like just another change
of prime minister on the basis of what
conservative MPS would like there's no
longer feel very Democratic and any
sense of a democratic mandate it's
getting more and more remote so it seems
to me normally that the mother of
parliament should be setting an example
to the world and putting an end to this
kind of chaos by having a general
election
it's good to talk to you my Lord thank
you very much indeed for joining us
thank you Kate
wow okay yes well I mean
those who have served in government with
with uh shock at what unfolded last
night and the point he made about Sue
Ella brathman the Home Secretary uh is
an interesting one she resigned over
what she said was a technical breach of
the rules but as Lord Ricketts pointed
out it was more of a parking ticket
offense if it is what she described
which is that she sent a confidential
information through her personal email
to another MP that she says would have
been made public later we don't know
what the intention was of what would
happen to that information but she said
that she had taken responsibility for
her mistakes and then with uh some
Barbed letter saying unlike some other
people who don't take responsibility for
their mistakes and said she had concerns
about the direction of this government
and these letters tend to be quite
polite it's in their resignation
statements in the House of Commons that
MPS often really go for it so we'll see
whether she gives that statement today
or at some point over the coming days we
should have that confirmed a bit later
but to lose a second senior member of of
the cabinet within a week just gives you
a sense of how this government is losing
grip and the scenes we saw last night
the government told MPS that fracking
something that lots of conservatives
oppose and in their Manifesto on which
they're elected in 2019 they said they
wouldn't do
they were
cajoled or Worse into voting for it
the government couldn't control what was
going on and he's always absolutely
chaotic scenes last night several of
those MPS made clear that even though it
was a three-line whip they were going to
break it because they felt so strongly
about the issue others said they will be
voting for it not because they wanted
fracking but simply to retain their
ability as a conservative MP to send in
their letter to oust the prime minister
so this is where we are the feeling
among senior members of the government
is this cannot go on for that much
longer but no one is very clear on how
this all might be brought to an end yeah
a senior Minister told me last night
that actually the documentary document
had been sent to a journalist rather
than to a colleague now if that was to
be the case that is leaking government
information and that would be a sackable
offense well the story we were told
yesterday is that she sent it to an
another mp uh John in 10 sent to another
MP John Hayes and had accidentally uh
sent it to another staffer in Parliament
who then reported to the chief whip so
it was certainly sent to from her
personal email to other people in
Parliament
um but if that additionally happened and
that would be where was it going after
that of course it may not have been
going anywhere further and that might be
the way that the government is spinning
that this morning I'm sure all will
become clear in the fullness of time
meantime Grassroots stories they've
expressed dismay at the turmoil in
Westminster a key brick in the tour is
red war games of 2019 Darlington had
become the poster child of the
government's leveling up policy but for
councilors and residents optimism is now
in short supply here's Iva
they say a week is a long time in
politics but right now just 24 hours is
these Tory councilors in Darlington
rapidly losing patience with the
never-ending changes in policy and
personnel
Bedlam I think it's absolute turmoil
it's disheartening we're listening to
people on a daily basis about their
frustrations about what's happening and
I think you know what my hope is now is
that they're going to sort it out
only one member of the group backed Liz
trust for leader but they all agree that
now is not the right time to replace her
it's the shambles if I'm if I'm honest
she's got to get her MPS coalescing
around her and it's just clearly not
happening that's what's causing all the
issues at the minute but what is a
political crisis for the conservatives
is the cost of living crisis for the
country as inflation continues to soar
for many here the main concern is not
who is in power but what's in their
pockets because for more and more people
just making ends meet is already
becoming a major struggle
379 please at darlington's indoor market
there's 150 years of history but
Shoppers are concerned only about the
future we're going to end up where we're
going to need two jobs
like just to live really you're
literally scrimming and scraping just to
buy milk bread and your Essentials I
mean I'm only eating one meal a day one
meal a day yeah because it's just too
too expensive yes it is
Robin Blair has been a Trader here for
70 years but has never seen prices rise
so steeply it's so uncertain you just
don't know where it's going to end at
and and how it's going to affect people
would you want to see more support from
the government yes definitely I think
they've got to help the support I mean
we all just it was looking a bit better
a week ago but now it's all up in the
air again
the only certainty tough times ahead for
politicians and the public Ivor Bennett
Sky News Darlington
uh chatting to somebody who says that
they saw what happened in the voting
lobbies yesterday that's Chris Bryant
he'll be joining us shortly before that
though
um tomorrow one wonders what the mood is
behind us this morning
I think it's
a sign of the chaos going on in there
that at 1 30 in the morning someone in
Downing Street was messaging journalists
including myself to say
just to confirm it was a confidence vote
the chief work and the deputy chief were
still in place and MPS who didn't vote
with the government last night are going
to be disciplined
if it took five hours to confirm whether
the chief whip was still in her post
this is not a government that's in
control of events I've got senior not
cabinet senior sort of conservatives now
speculating to me that this could all
come to an end very quickly possibly
even within the day nobody nobody really
knows but they feel that Liz trust
having lost two members of her cabinet
lost her economic program and now losing
control of her own MPS with don't forget
MPS who aren't Rebels who are supportive
of her leadership saying they weren't
going to vote with the government last
night because they simply didn't agree
with what they were doing and Liz truss
appearing to completely misjudge that
set of circumstances a government cannot
deal with all the many many challenges
facing everybody at home when they can't
come on and support their own MPS yeah
atori MP um telling some of our
colleagues that she's got 12 hours to
save her job what does what does this
government have to do to try to steady
the ship well in the words of the newest
member of the cabinet Grant shaps who
took his position at the home office
last night he said the task list trucker
has is like climbing Mount Everest it's
like threading the eye the thread
through the eye of the needle in the
dark
they know that restoring once lost
restoring Authority is almost impossible
to get back and so I think senior
members of the government are in no
doubt that I think and what that what's
keeping Liz trust in position is the
lack of a plan amongst those trying to
get rid of her those trying to get rid
of her who are plotting and meeting
across the road and in Parliament and in
bars and restaurants around central
London they know that if they want to
get rid of Liz trust they can't have
another contest lasting eight weeks they
need to have a candidate who can walk in
there and do the job and they cannot
unite around one and so you know Rishi
sunak is touted as the you know the
choice of MP so he has a kind of mandate
there he's not university-like include
you know members of the cabinet perhaps
wouldn't accept him so that is what's
holding this to us in position now and I
think there will be no doubt in the
building behind us K that things are
very very sticky indeed yeah
um a very fruity word was used to
describe Rishi soon actually afternoon
but who knows he might be our prime
minister by the end of the week I'm sure
he won't be stranger things have
happened even last night joining us now
is Health and Social care Committee
Member and also the shadow culture
Minister that's Rachel maskel hi Rachel
good to see you what did you see last
night
hello well obviously
um I'm here to talk about a really
important report that the health select
committee has put forward but it's
evident that there's not only chaos in
Westminster but clearly there's chaos
for GPS as well as they're in crisis and
we need to get those Solutions and
that's why we need a functioning
government to ensure that we can't
Implement change to help our NHS to make
sure that it gets back on track and that
our public are served by the government
I did want to talk to you about what the
reported find but I did want to ask you
first of all if I may about what
happened last night and what you were
aware of
well clearly there was chaos across
government and that continues and of
course through the the voting system we
saw people being ushered into the
lobbies to be able to support the
government I think the the government
now has two prime ministers it seems to
have two policies on everything and
complete chaos this isn't fair for the
public and it's not that we need a
change of prime minister it's that we
need a change of government now
who's the other prime minister
well there's clearly one at number 10
and wonder One at number 11 and it seems
that the one at number 11 seems to be
pulling the strings now and trying to
reform this government but of course
what we need to ensure is that we've got
a government which can function and fix
the crises that people across the
country are facing whether that's with
the cost of living or indeed our
National Health Service
tell me about the report and what it
found
well it's a very serious report that the
health select committee engaged in an
inquiry across the the Primary Care
Community General practice
we must first of all recognize how hard
GPS are working 8.9 increase in demand
and yet the number of GPS more leaving
than than coming into the profession the
government committed to 6 000 new GPS
and we've seen just 1
672 GPS coming on stream and of course
that is not going to address the
challenges we've got because more GPS
are having to work part-time over 50
percent because they just cannot cope
with the levels of workloads so they may
be working a reduced number of sessions
but volunteering so to speak for the
rest of the week to catch up with
Administration and other tasks
associated with their work so first of
all we need to ensure that we've got a
Workforce which is fit for the future
but behind that we need to ensure that
we've got continuity of care patients
and that's what our report really draws
out the benefit that continuity of care
brings not only in ensuring that people
access the service in the right place
less than missions to a e and hospital
for people with dementia that has got to
be a plus but what constant research
showed including from the University of
Bergen is that Health outcomes improve
but also mortality Falls when people
have direct relationship with their GP
and what the report recommends is that
GPS go back to the system of having a
list that means people have a name GP a
GP which knows them knows their
condition and is able to plan for their
health into the future better outcomes
will come for that and that means it's
better for everyone
what if we see um a cut in the amount of
money that the NHS has to play with some
suggestions
um that the new Chancellor May impose 15
across all departments
well the new chance law was very much
part of this inquiry and I hope it will
be at the Forefront of his mind what
needs to happen in general practice we
need to see Primary Care driving our
health services the community
connectivity which is really important
for people's long-term Health including
Public Health making sure people don't
get sick in the first place but also for
people with complex needs and disabled
people being able to have that direct
contact with the GP we absolutely
essential so I call them the chancellor
to make sure the NHS is fully funded
properly funded to bring that Headroom
which is needed in primary care to Pivot
to a greater relationship between GP and
their patients better for GP mobile as
well as bringing forward the necessary
measures to increase the number of staff
and of course we're not just talking
about GPS and primary care we're talking
about District nurses physios and mental
health support workers as well to ensure
that we've got got the full complement
of healthcare professionals to support
the public
Rachel I think you made the right
decision being in the studio today it's
absolutely bucketing down here thanks
very much indeed for the update on the
report much appreciated thank you thanks
a lot couple of days ago I was stood
just here chatting to this lady Katie
ball she's back with us again
24 hours is a long time in politics 48
Hours look what's happened yeah I think
there's trust is discovering when it
rains it pause as are we but ultimately
her situation has got worse what's
interesting was it wasn't prime
minister's questions that did it that
there was almost a brief period of calms
right after prime minister's questions
so MPS were saying to me she has a few
weeks but then all of a sudden things
got a lot worse through the departures
through Ella Brave women her home
secretary and then the chaos last night
regarding that fracking vote
what happened with sweater Brown from
them because it's not because she sends
a document to another MP yeah yeah well
I think there's been bad blood between
Savannah braveman and Liz trust tension
for some time regarding immigration
because see let in the resignation
letter the fact that Savannah Raven said
she had doubts and concerns about the
direction and the ultimate need to bring
that migration down we know that Liz
truss wants to relax uh immigration when
it comes to highly skilled labor and
that's something that develop Raven is
very skeptical of and of course she
comes from the brexitier wing of the
party and she was a former leadership
rival to Liz tras so is this trust now
at risk of losing the right of the party
um because that could put her in an even
more dangerous position
um do you sense the hand of the de facto
prime minister on the shoulder of the
Prime Minister making these decisions uh
so Jeremy Hunt I think I think what's
interesting was when Jeremy Hunt was
hired uh was appointed and ultimately in
Downing Street they saw the left of the
party as the greater danger to Liz truss
they thought the right of the party had
few options to go to in terms of
successor they didn't think enough to
add a brave and have enough MPS whereas
on the left Rishi sunak penny more than
Jeremy Hunt and the idea was to bring
some of these supporters into the tent
but now seeing I think that it's having
a a backfiring effect with some of the
others and clearly Jeremy Hunt is in a
really powerful position we know that we
hear that he wanted to bring a wider
range of talents into the cabinet now I
don't know if this was exactly the way
to do it which is losing your second
great stay of office since Friday but
clearly now have Branch chaps who was
originally student background and is
leaning to their Aim so Jeremy Hunt has
more to be pleased about right now than
the right of tea I mean he's been
plotting against this prime minister the
new Home Secretary since she got in yeah
well this is it Grant shapes as you say
he likes to tell everyone about his
spreadsheet yeah uh his list of MPS and
how they feel often not being very
positive towards this trust and
therefore there's one thing to have your
you know your enemies inside but I think
at this point what is Grant shaft's plan
is he really going to help to unify the
government or do we have a situation
where people think that Liz truss is
going to be out in a matter of time and
they're getting into positions so
they're in a powerful place when it
comes to the debate over the future of
the party okay um do you think there'll
be more resignations slash sackings to
come I didn't even rule that out
um I think that it's interesting for
example that Steve Baker so Salas who
had a braveman European research group
breakfast here last night was still
saying Liz trust deserves more time now
there's lots of ministers who don't
think that and but she still has a
little bit of support and I think today
is going to be very difficult for her it
could be event that just escalates if
there are more cabinet resignations I
think it gets really difficult because
that's what position for Boris Johnson
so if we lived class to last a week she
needs her cabinet to stay solid
um how much danger is she in today I
think she's in the greatest danger she's
been in yet
um walking around Parliament last night
MPS are just despairing and lots of
people are now saying the situation is
just untenable so that's just oust and
worry later there's still a problem
though which is there's no Unity around
a candidate there's no consensus and
therefore it's a little bit too hard to
say exactly what's going to happen but
it's going to be a very difficult day
for Liz trust and potentially a
difficult weekend and the thing that's
saving her as a lot of people are saying
is because there isn't anyone that they
can point to to say it's going to be
that person I heard a very fruity word
used for Rishi sunak yesterday can he
unite the party I Think It's Tricky for
us to search you know at the party
there's still lots of bad blood from
Boris Johnson supporters but I actually
think it's tricky for anyone to unite
the party right now even if a candidate
is seen as a unifier as soon as they
make decisions they'll upset a certain
Wing though people are asking where is
United you know ultimately I'd say well
they had one MP you say to me he needs
to say he wants this or say he doesn't
because it's stopping others from coming
forward so I think there is a growing
sense that people need to stop coming
out and discussing the options yeah I
mean they are going to find a way
through this get out the rain it's good
to see you thanks very much indeed as
always Katie thank you so we're standing
outside down the street again this
morning in the rain and that is because
the prime minister is under the most
precious she's been under since she took
office what's happened stay tuned and
find out
[Music]